welcome back when i left off i was
rushing at the end of this problem
because i tend to rush at the end of
problems when i um am getting close to
the youtube 10 minute limit but i just
wanted to review the end of it because i
fell feel like i rushed it and then
actually continue with it and actually
solve for the angle and introduce a
little bit of a little more trigonometry
so just to review what we did we said
momentum is conserved and in two
dimensions that means momentum is
conserved in each of the dimensions so
we figured out what the initial momentum
of the entire system was and we said
well in the x direction the initial
momentum and all the momentum was coming
from the ball a right because ball b
wasn't moving so its velocity was zero
so momentum was zero so ball a in the x
direction and it was only moving in the
x direction so its momentum in the x
direction was three meters per second
times 10 kilogram meters per second we
got 30 kilogram meters per second and
then there was no momentum in the in the
y direction
and then we we knew that well after they
hit each other ball a kind of ricochets
off at a 30 degree angle at 2 meters per
second we use that information to figure
out the x and y components of a's
velocity so a's velocity in the y
direction was 1 meter per second and a's
direction a's velocity in in the x
direction was square root of 3.
and we used that information to figure
out is momentum in each direction we
said well the momentum in the y
direction must be one meter per second
times a's mass which is 10 kilogram
meters per second which i wrote
wait right what i wrote here
and then we figured out a's momentum in
the b direction
and we said well that's just going to be
square root of 3 times 10 and that's 10
square roots of 3. and then we use that
information to solve for b's momentum
because we said well b's momentum plus
a's momentum in the x direction has to
add up to 30 right this was the x
direction before
and we knew that b's momentum plus
a's momentum in the y direction had to
add up to zero right
and so since y's momentum going upwards
was
kilogram meters per second we knew that
b's momentum going downwards would also
have to be 10 kilograms per second or
you could even say it's negative 10. and
we figured that out based on the fact
that b had half the mass
that its velocity going down was 2
meters per second and similarly we knew
that a's
a's momentum in the x direction plus
which was 10 squares of 3 kilogram
meters per second plus b's momentum in
the x direction is equal to 30 and then
we just subtracted out and we got b's
momentum in the x direction and then we
divided by b's mass to get its velocity
which we got as
2.54 so that's where i left off and we
were rushing and
already this gives you a sense of what b
is doing although it's broken up into
the x and y direction now if we wanted
to simplify this if we wanted to
kind of write b's new velocity the same
way that the problem gave us a's
velocity right they told us a's velocity
was 2 meters per second at an angle of
30 degrees we now have to use this
information to figure out
b's velocity and and the angle of it
and how do we do that well this is just
straight up trigonometry at this point
or really just straight up geometry so
if we
let me clear all of this let's remember
these two numbers 2.54 and minus 2.
so b
we we learned that in the x direction
its velocity this is all for b is equal
to 2.54
meters per second
and then the y direction it was moving
down
we could write this as minus two
we could write this as minus 2 but
i'll just write this as 2 meters per
second downwards
down
right same thing minus 2 up is the same
thing as 2 meters per second down
so the resulting vector is going to look
something like this
when you add two vectors you just put
them
put the ones
end at the beginning of the other one
put put them
front to end like we did here and then
you add them together and this is the
resulting vector and i think you're used
to that at this point
and now we have to figure out this angle
and this side well this side is easy
because this is a right angle so we use
pythagorean theorem so this is going to
be
the square root
of 2.54
squared plus 2 squared
and what's 2.54 squared
2.54
times
time whoops
2.5
times
2.54
is equal to 6.45
so that's the square root of 6.45
plus 4
which equals the square root of 10.45
so let's see plus 4 equals 10.45 and
take the square root of that so that's
3.2 roughly
3.2 so it's the resulting velocity in
this direction whatever angle this is is
3.2 meters per second
and i just use pythagorean theorem so
now all we have to do is figure out the
angle and we could use a bunch of we
could use
really any of the trig ratios because we
know all of the sides so i don't know
let's let's use one that you you feel
comfortable with well
let's use sine
so sine of theta
sine
of theta is equal to what
sohcahtoa sine is opposite over
hypotenuse so the opposite side is the y
direction so that's 2
over the hypotenuse 3.2
so 2 divided by 2 divided by 3.2 is
equal to
0.625
which equals 0.625
so sine of theta equals 0.65 and maybe
you're not familiar with arcsine yet
because i don't think i actually have
covered it yet in the trig modules but
although i will eventually
so we know it's just the inverse
function of sine
so sine of theta
is equal to 0.625 then we know that
theta is equal to
the arc sine
of 0.625 this is essentially saying when
you say arc sine this is tell me the
angle whose sine is this number that's
what arc sine is
and we can take out google because it
actually
it actually happens that google has a
let's see
google actually it's an automatic
calculator so you could type in arc sine
on google
of 0.625
although i think the there's the
answer they give you will be in radians
so i'll take that answer that'll be in
radians and i want to convert to degrees
so i multiply it times 180 over pi
that's just how i convert from radians
to degrees
and let's see what i get
so google you see google says
38.68 degrees
and they multiplied the whole thing
times 180 and then divided by pi but
that should be the same thing so 38 so
roughly 38.7 degrees
is theta hope you understand that
you could pause it here if you don't but
let me just write that down so it's 38
degrees
38.7 so theta is equal to 38.7
degrees so then we're done
we figured out that ball b gets hit
this is ball b and it got hit by ball a
ball a went off in that direction at a
30 degree angle
at a 30 degree angle at 2 meters per
second
and now ball b goes at
38 point or we could say roughly 39
degrees below the horizontal
at a velocity of 3.2 meters per second
and and does this does this intuitively
make sense to you
well if you remember the problem from
before and i know i erased everything
ball a was had a mass of 10 kilograms
while ball b had a mass of five
kilograms
so it makes sense so let's think about
just the y direction ball a we figured
out it's what it the y component of its
velocity was one meters per second one
meter per second and ball b's y
component is two meters per second
downwards and does that make sense well
sure
because their momentums have to add up
to zero there was no
y component of the momentum before we
before they hit each other
in order for b to have the same
momentum going downwards in the y
direction as a going upwards its
velocity has to be essentially double
because its mass is half
and a similar logic although the
the cosine doesn't it doesn't work out
exactly like that but a similar logic
would mean that its overall velocity is
going to be faster than the
going in than a's velocity
and so
what was i just saying oh yeah yeah yeah
okay i
my phone was ringing and i got i got
caught up
my brain starts to starts to malfunction
but anyway what i was saying so just
intuitively it makes sense b has a
smaller mass than a so it makes sense
that one b will be going faster and that
it gets deflected a little bit more as
well and i mean the reason why it seems
like it gets deflected more is because
it's y component is more but anyway that
last piece is just to kind of hopefully
give you a sense of what's happening and
i will see you in the next video